Chưa hai mì sau tháng tám tại Hàn Nội, bộ khó hợp và tung nghệ,
vối hợp băn tinh giáo và dân bận Trung ương bộ văn hóa thị thào và dù liệt,
tổ chức lễ khác thành đặc biệt, bộ tâm bư chính kiện nghiệp tả mùi năm
khó khánh nước cộng hòa sã hội chủ nghĩa Việt Nam.
Tới dự có đồng chỉ, ũi viên bộ chính chỉ, bí thư chủ ương đàn,
trở băn tinh giáo và tân bận Trung ương, đồng chỉ, ũi viên chú ương đàn,
phó chủ tĩ có khói, cùng đại diện lãnh đạo các bộ băn ngàn trụ ương.
Bộ tâm bộ bộ tâm và một lúc,
bộ tâm khắc hả hình tự chủ tĩ có chí mình,
người khais tinh ra nước Việt Nam sân chủ cộ hà
vàng phong cách nghệ thật đồ hà hiện đại,
vừa chân nghiêm vừa gần gũi, hương hợp bắc hiện tư,
anh mắt sáng người nghiêm tinh và khách bọc lập tự gó trở dân tóc.
Những đường nét sản tị như tinh tế,
kết thập cùng sách đỏ vàng trụ đạo khổ khó tì,
đã làm lời bất tâm bóc của vì lãnh tụi viết dài
biểu tượng bất viet của tinh thần yêu nước và khách bọng hà bình.
Mộ bà lóc, thế hiện có khuy nước cộ hà sã hội chú nghĩa Việt Nam
và bản đồ tổ quốc với trọng vệnh chú quyền biến đau.
Nên bước, là hình anh chống đồng biểu tượng nằm đam vật hiện
hợp nhé khổ buồn lịch sử và chíu sư và hòa sân tóc.
Bộ tâm gió hòa sĩ nghiệm dù thiết kế,
có quân khổ ba mì hai nhìn bộn biệt ba mì li mê,
có giám mặt bún hình đồng,
bước tâm người trên một chăm mê li mê,
giám mở chỉ hình hình đồng.
Bộ tâm được cũng ở trên tòa ngốc,
từ ngày 20 sâu tâm nằm hà nhìn thục trọng hà miệnh làm.
Đến hết bà mời thằng sảo nằm hà nhìn thục trọng hà miệnh bây.